As Amazon celebrates its 20th anniversary,...
...let's take a look at four major challenges it faces on its road ahead.
One: slow international growth particularly in China,...
...where it's failed to make meaningful headway against Chinese e-commerce giant Alibaba...
...and other local players.
Two: new challengers in the US,...
...with online marketplace Jet.com offering a variety of products at a discount to members,...
...and Instacart, a direct competitor to Amazon's Prime Fresh service.
Three: the lack of a desirable mobile phone in its portfolio,...
...which leaves it completely dependent on others as more shopping moves to mobile.
And four: the strong chance that brick-and-mortar retailers like Walmart...
...finally develop cohesive and successful e-commerce strategies.
Amazon has been enjoying double-digit revenue growth,...
...but that growth has slowed in recent years.
Its 2010 to 2011 growth of 41% went down to more than half...
...to only 20% growth from 2013 to 2014,...
...suggesting that some of these headwinds may be impacting the company.